with the new year under way we're all
looking forward to the games of 2014 the
experiences that are going to define our
gaming years when they actually come out
but some of the games that are going to
make waves in 2014 are actually playable
right now through Steam early access a
program that lets you buy and play games
while they're still in development there
are a lot of early access games
currently available with more coming
every week and while some are totally
playable and fun others are still pretty
rough so today and every day this week
i'll be your host as we take a look at a
bunch of steam early access games to
give you an idea of what's worth playing
what's worth waiting for and what else
going on in this brave new world of
giving people money to play their games
before their games are actually done
today's crop of games all believe that
the world is a dangerous place with
secrets worth pursuing at any cost
Maxwell McGee spent some time delving
into dungeons of the endless and came
back with a weird penchant for geometric
shapes let's find out why
dungeon of the endless may wear the
guise of a roguelike but at its heart
it's a tower defense game in brief you
control the last two survivors of a
crashed spaceship and must protect the
ship's core from waves of enemies while
simultaneously exploring the many rooms
of a subterranean dungeon each one of
these rooms is blocked off by a door
opening a door earns you resources to
upgrade your characters and build
defenses but it could also trigger
enemies to pop out an attack you
sometimes these enemies appear in the
room you just entered and sometimes they
appear in a room you visited three doors
back by playing smart and carefully
choosing which doors to open you can
funnel enemies down a single path and
into your turns eventually you will find
a room containing the exit which leads
to the next floor of the dungeon this is
an exciting moment in the game since it
means you must go back to your ship grab
the Power Core and slowly carry it to
the exit oh and while you're doing this
the enemies will endlessly pop up around
you and your turrets will start shutting
down and they're not gonna stop so you
really need to hurry
Grim Dawn does the title refer to
sunrise in a war-torn Kingdom an
encounter with a stern mafioso or the
morning after a hard night out kevin van
oort has your answer but spoilers its
first one
click happy top down action check deep
dark dungeons check spells and swords
and side quests check check and check
you've played games like this before and
grim dawn isn't steamrolling tradition
with a groundbreaking new action
role-playing game in fact grim dawn is
so tied to tradition that I wish it
looked further beyond the typical diablo
clone tropes and establish an identity
of its own yet with the tried-and-true
design comes the kind of absorbing
looting and levelling that keeps you
gazing at the screen for hours at a time
2999 gets you at least 10 hours of solid
single player exploration all of them
brought to you by the lead gameplay
designer of titan quest and those are 10
refined well-structured hours for work
in progress Grim Dawn certainly feels
complete with a few of the interface
quirks and glitches that characterize
unfinished software in time more acts
cooperative options and other content
will build upon this solid foundation
with dual class leveling competing
factions and lots of nooks and crannies
to investigate Grim Dawn seems a
no-brainer given the developers proven
pedigree and the stability and elegance
of the game in its current form
to close out today's trio I've got a
personal favor to share with you n yes
it's yet another one of those games
where you can mutate your butt to make
yourself more powerful what can I say
I've got predictable tastes have a
look-see at nuclear throne of all the
grim and fantastical apocalyptic worlds
video games have brought into our lives
none is quite like nuclear throne in
this unforgiving shoot amor beat-'em-up
action game you pick a weird mutant and
then try to blast your way past a host
of weird mutants in order to sit upon
the nuclear throne and proclaim yourself
king of the weird mutants there's a fish
that can dodge roll a robot that eats
guns and poops mo a speedy carnivorous
plant and a thing named eyes with a ton
of eyes each character has a passive
trait and an active ability that you
need to exploit to survive and as you
level up you gain new mutations that can
heavily influenced your play style you
got to watch your ammo choose your
weapons wisely bob and weave and for
heaven's sake don't die because this is
a roguelike and I'll lose everything
look no crap ah dammit nuts though more
levels more characters more secret
worlds and other stuff are coming before
launch it feels like the core action of
nuclear throne is fairly complete it's
fast paced and brutal but it's kept me
coming back for more than a few hours
now thinking I'll do better this time I
usually don't but with slow-motion
powers and a deadly blade I'm gonna make
those mutant scum remember the
blindfolded chicken ninja names chicken
that's it for today but tomorrow and
every day this week will be rustling up
a bunch of steam early access games for
your be knowledge mint and enjoy itude
let us know what you thought of today's
games in the comments below and we'll
see you tomorrow